the star shade is like a large bicycle
wheel but it has to fit on top of a
rocket so when we launched it it deploys
its pedals it then expands its inner
structure almost to the size of a
baseball diamond this large structure
has its own propulsion system and it
propels itself in the direction of a
target star and then the telescope will
lag behind and then it blocks that light
from the star and then we can take a
picture of it we are really excited
about exoplanets for one of the oldest
questions known to man are we alone
an exoplanet is a planet that orbits
another storm we were 90 percent of all
the exoplanets that have been discovered
have not actually been imaged because a
star so bright and the planet is so
faint the biggest technology is being
able to block the glare of the star in
this room here this is our star shade
laboratory we are developing
technologies to do just that so one
important aspect of the star shade is
that you cannot just have a disk the
light will band around the disk into the
telescope so what you need is a
precisely shaped star shade that bends
the light around the petals and into an
annulus around the telescope one of the
biggest challenges is we have this very
large 22 meter diameter star shade these
six meter petals that has to stow into a
very small 5 meter launch fairing we had
an engineer here that was working on
origami inspired solar arrays and you
came up with this design that can take a
flat sheet and stow it up and you can
see here as it deploys deploys out into
a star shade like structure
this hardware we developed to look at
how do we wrap the pedals and tie them
down for launch so you can imagine each
one of these long set of metal spines
here represents the pedals in their
length so what we can do is practice
stowing up pairs of pedals and figuring
out how do we tie them down for launch
one of the goals of our technology
development here is to be ready to fly
in the mid 2020s
if we can find planets that have
atmospheres and maybe rocky planets like
our own earth that increases the
possibilities that life may exist